let's have a look at this and I first
easy to do before you go anywhere and
start this question is actually to come
back to this guy right and to say well
I'm sorry to say which one of these is
relevant okay man
woman look at the question it's a woman
right so I'm gonna write this down right
away that's the first thing I'm gonna do
okay this question sinks I've written
now that relevant formula now I want to
see how the question requires me to use
it okay
they give us a whole bunch of
information they tell us it's one we
already know that they've told us her
mass and it says she wants to keep her
blood alcohol table 0.05 why is that
because she wants to stand with the
legal limit okay
how many drinks did she consume in three
hours so what you have a look out of all
of these things you've written down
which of them do you have numbers that
you can substitute for okay em em I know
what a mass is I also know what H is
right that's the three hours I know that
is what else do I know
yeah okay we want herb like alcohol
content to be point oh five or less does
that make sense
so I'm just going to put in point four
five and I want you to remember the part
that's all this case because we're gonna
solve this for a second now have a look
at that one two three things that I'm
gonna substitute in for me to think back
to am one substitution this is just an
algebra question there's one letter one
pro new rule left what is it why is it
left over cuz yeah I don't know what it
is so that's why I'm going to solve for
that okay you ready let's do the
substitution that's inside I've got 0.05
I've got ten and I have to write in
because I don't know what it is take
away all right what about here 7.5
times 3 divided by what's on the
denominator times 56 yeah okay cool a
whole bunch of numbers here what am I
gonna do with all this it's a bit of a
mess okay what I really want is this 10
in business okay so I'm gonna simplify
this a little bit and then I'm going to
do some rearrangement so can I get some
people to tell me what 7.5 times 3 I
think it's 22.5 yep good 22.5 can
someone tell me the denominator exactly
yes okay do you know why do you know why
I actually you can you can knows very
good see this right this is 2 times 28
or 2 times whatever but look as soon as
you double that it becomes 11 so it's a
whole number so that's why I'm trying to
get to the end now right I want to get
that in by itself so what would you like
me to do first this is just an algebra
question now good I'm multiplying to you
by 308 308 times the point or 5 is it
sorry saying it yep
15 point now what do I do I'm going to I
couldn't divine or I could add but I
think adding to be better because then I
can avoid like decimals when I think as
long as possible so I'll add twenty two
point five to both sides which gives me
thirty seven point nine and last step
now I'm ready to divide so I'll put the
end on the left hand side as well that
gives me three point five seven nine
okay now remember right at the top when
I had the formula and substitute numbers
into it I substituted you imported five
on the left but I asked you to remember
something what am i what about you
remember
Poynter Fievel s right so that means
3.79 is the exact number of standard
drinks that we'll get to exactly two
point five right so how many drinks can
she consumed in three hours
this is gonna be this or less right yes
sir I'd say I'd say therefore she could
drink or she could consume 3.79 standard
drinks all that's
or you could say she can consume a
maximum of 3.75